thank you
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great oh yeah you were supposed to
be here combined all right whatever
whatever wow whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am
spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish
[Music]
to you and I think you know it
wanna get out of here oh win
so wait a minute there's an elite crew
with all the best spider people in it
who's the new guy this is unbelievable
this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing with his
idea what's it I gotta do to join this
spider team you can never be part of
this don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter miles you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home I can't do that I can do
both Spider-Man always always what about
Uncle Ben if not for Uncle Ben most of
us wouldn't be here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
no idea what are you doing
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman
and I looked at my uncle and ah let me
guess he died